red flag green flag they wear full face
paint to a game cool too much that's too
much I like
it they wear the same pair of socks for
every game stinky that's gross that's
cool you know same smelly oh smelly what
no I mean they're washed right sure
social events around their favorite VI I
like that that's cool so we got here
green flag 100% of course can't named
the starting five red flag fake fan not
a real fan fake fan not acceptable
Warrior fan Faker fan
they Canim the entire roster down to the
end of the bed I can so that's yeah
that's they spend a lot of time yeah can
you they refer to their team as we
that's cool yeah I like that I do we are
champions 100% we it's definitely a we
they know all of their player social
media handles that's a little weird
that's fine I like that yeah I kind of
like both they leave games early to beat
traffic beat traffic leave games early
oh no no no no no ooh red flag stay
there 100% red flag oh red flag